أول شيء يجب أخذه في الاعتبار هنا
يقول العلماء
أنه لا داعي للقلق بشأن
هذا ، فهذه ليست نهاية الأيام ،
نعم هناك صاروخ صيني يزن 22 طنًا
يندفع
حول العالم بسرعة
18000 ميل في الساعة وهو  من المحتمل أن تضرب
مكانًا ما
في العالم بمجرد دخولها
الغلاف الجوي للأرض والذي يُعتقد أنه
من المحتمل أن يحدث في الفترة ما بين 8 مايو
وهو يوم السبت ، وقد يكون يوم السبت 9 مايو
، أو العاشر من مايو ، لذلك
هناك فرصة في أحد تلك الأيام الثلاثة لأن هذا
الشيء كذلك
يبلغ حجم تمثال الحرية البالغ 22 طنًا تقريبًا خمس حجم
تمثال الحرية الأمريكي مطروحًا منه القاعدة ،
لذلك لديك
قطع معدنية كبيرة قد لا تحترق
عند إعادة الدخول مثل معظم الأشياء التي تسقط
من الفضاء
ويمكن أن تهبط  على الأرجح
يقول العلماء إن المحيط
الهادي هو الأكبر فوق المحيط ، لذا
ربما تكون هناك فرصة أن ينزل
هنا في منطقة المحيط الهادئ أو
المحيط الأطلسي ، حيث تكون فرص
إصابة أي شخص
ضئيلة جدًا ولكن ما هو
إذا سقط الحطام في منطقة مكتظة بالسكان
مثل هنا في هونغ كونغ أو نيويورك ، فقد
وقعت حوادث في الماضي حيث
دخلت الصواريخ مرة أخرى وأصابت القطع
مناطق بها أشخاص ، كانت هناك قرية
صغيرة أصيبت
بضربة  أنبوب يبلغ طوله 12 مترًا منذ عدة سنوات ،
ولم يكن هناك أضرار أو إصابات كبيرة هناك ،
ولكن عندما تتحدث عن سيناريو آخر ،
فإن أسوأ سيناريو
يمكن أن يكون
مثيرًا للقلق ، والشيء المثير للدهشة والقلق
حول هذا الأمر هو أنهم لن يعرفوا
أين  سيضرب هذا الشيء حتى
ساعات قبل الاصطدام حرفيًا
بسبب السرعات العالية التي
يسافر بها الحطام لمسافة
18000 ميل في الساعة الواحدة يمكن أن تحدث
فرقًا بين
التأثير في منطقة واحدة أو في مكان ما على
بعد 18000 ميل
ولكن الدرس الذي نحتاج جميعًا إلى تعلمه
هنا أن
هذه الأشياء
ستحدث أنها ستحدث وقد يحدث أكثر
لأن الصين ستطلق
المزيد من الصواريخ الكبيرة مثل هذا أثناء
عملهم نحو إكمال صواريخهم
كان من المفترض أن تكون محطة السرعة بنهاية 2022 و 2021 هي
العام الذي
عاد فيه كل شيء إلى طبيعته ، وسيصبح
ريبلي سي إن هونغ كونغ